bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
tania je souhaitais cros cole nos cités
françaises qui a plein de produits qui
sont vraiment top des produits pour
l'extérieur
est ce que tu peux déjà nous reparler un
petit coup de crosse colle un petit
historique rapide et tu nous présenter
les derniers nés les produits et
d'accessoires à tout ça
[Musique]
quand j'aurai tout nous sommes tous ici
un mobile world congress à barcelone
et pour cette édition nous sommes
exc
dans ce nouveau mais vous
nouveau bébé est sorti construire il est
sorti en fin de l'année et
et c'est un téléphone qui à ibos la
famille du coup ça veut dire qu'il peut
aller lancelot jusqu'à 12 mètres de
profondeur
madame douceur si on les perd après
les téléphones il est un raciste un il a
passé la norme militaire ik 0,4 dans
militaire ça veut dire quoi dans ces
moines ont mis dix personnes parlent pas
c'est à dire est qu'il est frais marais
sistani les il est passé avec est
perdante his own
j'aimerais qu'on respecte les télés n'a
pas bougé il est fourni avec vori la
glace il a cette technologie xlii c'est
très intéressant
ça c'est ce que tu me disais tu peux du
coup sur des supports aimanté exactement
tout partager de l'information dont on
ne peut les attacher les vélos dans la
voiture tu peux partager l'information
de téléphone vers l'ordinateur après toi
en bataille estime sa place à ces
téléphones qui a tout sauf un raciste m
du coup tu peux te rappelles tu peux
aussi me mettre dans la voiture sur le
vélo on s'en doutait des petits clips
sur le côté tu m'expliquer ce sont
quelque part si jamais on va trop fort
en betty très exactement par cap est
notre rien ce n'est des clients nous
fait des portraits et sportives
ils s'aiment bien les terrains hostiles
semiane aller dans l'eau il sait bien
aux aventuriers comme si le volume
partir que je ne sais pas si c'est ça le
progrès des bâtiments aussi sur la
notion que c'est pas grave s'il est
révolue s'est sali à la fin des poules
avait le téléphone
comme nouveau patron donc là on voit
qu'on en a par exemple pieds dans l'eau
derrière sur le poids bien tu peux le
laisser combien de temps émerger celui
là est
celui là allez les filles la journée
c'est l'exposition les bonnes il est pas
immergées beaucoup de promeneurs mais
sinon la loi il dit que tous voulaient
immergée du maître pénale du sort de m
engager les syndicats qui ont dû dire
n'est pas de l'eau salée uniquement de
l'eau douce note voulait mettre à l'eau
salée après comme c est recommandé et
tout mais la marque legend ou
on sent la bim-sa simple
alors qu'au côté puissance quand elle
qu'est ce qu'on a le processeur les noms
de l'art avec moi dedans
qui est mon goût
mémoire des 32 gigas et il est
extrêmement dur car sans papiers et
il est avec un drôle tantôt une nouvelle
cette fois nous a appelés
et il a un appareil photo de 12
mégapixels à l'arrière et cinq mairies
celle à la main
[Musique]
il a un processeur d'entrée morts
l'application
ça marche pitra va bien ça veut partir
mais très contente avec les téléphones
ce que tu me disais qu'ils étaient super
intéressant c'est les capteurs j'avais
plein de capteurs
les produits sont des capteurs pour voir
la mine east et la team être le terme au
maire
eq hygromètre qu'on a des centres modèle
aussi les traits quelle histoire
il cherche aussi palin tokyo sauf que là
bas la technologie
hélas la boussole et c'est bien pour
quelque chose avec donc effectivement
quand tu vas en haïti dessus ça te dit à
quelle hauteur tués la pression
extérieure s'attaque à plus aussi
by ap leur est commun va essayer
si je peux les obtenir
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'ils m'ont
il a forcément comme il est
produit qui est hyper sécurisé il un
volume assez conséquent il n'est pas
feinte c'est normal aussi tout c'est un
produit extérieur après sommes croisés
3,1 g s'est passé ça change de téléphone
mais bon notre analyse non mais il est
bien sûr la taille de l'écran qui la
connaît oui fait 5-5 booth ok c'est de
l'écran lcd j'imagine oui c'est dell a
cédé
un peu m s'est ouverte à peine
les faire encore plus résistantes
d'accord tu veux tu as une seule carte
sim qui porte à 2 402 adobe sept modèles
et axione x3 et babar soit le quart
visite
ma une carte sim m² pour monter la
batterie jusqu'à fabre à la mémoire
jusqu'à 128 go
j'ai compris bon mais qu'on super est ce
que tu vas d'autres choses dans la vie
qui peut nous faire un petit institut
sur cros cole nour explique un peu
l'histoire la société d'un creux de nos
cinq semaines sa princesse on est au sud
de la france avec sa province
et on en a perdu
on a commencé 2009 avec notre série
d'ivan et il a remarqué le vaisseau md
et téléphone tout à l'heure et il a dit
on avait scindé ou téléphone d'eau
y a une autonomie de batterie principe
est simple
mais petit à petit on nous fait des
innovations sommer demandé les
voilà les clés année c'est bien ça
marche de lyon louis en bande ku sur des
vélos des l'europe
aubade et l'italie et l'espagne
la zone ni la piste bien tu auras les
nordiques
uk vous êtes présent sur le marché
américain par les ricains machine est
pas encore été évoquée mais bientôt ce
faire ok génial alors du coup tu me dis
que vous étiez aidé tout au début comme
prennent style qu'on développement de la
pêche c'est qu'elle nous a donné
plusieurs filles parce que j'aime bien
les
notre croissance notre jeunesse notre
innovation et
oui nos filles c'est une entreprise
française qui réussit qui est innovante
parce que sur les smartphones de
français il n'ya pas grand chose donc il
y en a 2 ou vous êtes un des 2 donc
coscoll le génial merci beaucoup
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez à
ce que vous connaissez cros cole est ce
que des produits comme celui là pourrait
vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez des besoins est ce
que vous êtes un petit baroudeur en
aventurier vous avez des besoins pour
avoir un téléphone solide pour toutes
vos balades vos promenades vous
randonnez vos aventures marquis mode
sans commentaires sont les bienvenus
bien évidemment comme d'habitude à vous
abonner à mener cette jolie course on
reste connectés
merci à toi mais reviennent pas à
bientôt
[Musique]